Janell is training for a road race her
pedometer tracks how far she runs every
day here are the pedometer readings for
the past four days so on Saturday she
went three point eight nine miles sunday
five point one Monday ten point two one
Tuesday three point three five estimate
the total distance you ran over the four
days and then calculate the exact amount
so let's estimate first so I'm just
going to round them to the nearest mile
so three point eight nine let's round it
up to four miles and I'm doing that
because in the tenths place we have an
eight it is 5 or greater so let's just
make that roughly four miles let's make
this five point one we round that down
because this one is less than five so
let's do make this five miles ten point
two one let's make that ten miles let's
make that ten miles because two would
round down it's less than five and the
three point three five let's make that
three miles because three is less than 5
so we'd round down so that is three
miles and if we were to add them up 4
plus 5 is 9 9 plus 10 is 19 19 plus 3 is
22 so my estimate my estimate is that
she ran 22 miles over the four days
that's my estimate now let's figure out
the exact amount that she ran so let me
scroll down a little bit so we're going
to have to add we need to add three
point eight nine two five point one and
remember when you're adding decimals you
want to line up the decimal ten point
two one ten point two one and then
finally three point three five three
point three five and let's add all of
these up now we'll start in the
hundredths place nine plus there's
nothing here so nine plus nothing plus
one is 10 plus 5 is 15
so let's write the five and then carry
or regroup the one-one-one let me do
this in another color 1 plus 8 is 9 9
plus 1 is 10 10 plus 2 is 12
of 12 plus 3 is 15 put the five down
carry or regroup the 1 1 plus 3 is 4 4
plus 5 is 9 9 plus 0 is still 9 9 plus 3
is 12 9 plus 3 is 12
write the two regroup this one right
here I'll do it out here just so it's
not part of any of these numbers and
then 1 plus 1 is 2 and then we have to
remember the decimal sitting right over
there so the exact amount the exact
distance you ran was twenty two point
five five miles our estimate wasn't too
bad it was 22 miles so we got reasonably
close within about little over half a
mile